plus we begin tonight with the rushed of
politicization in the wake of tragedy
earlier today the president commented on
the tragic horrific shooting at the
Capitol Gazette newspaper in Annapolis
Maryland
this attack shocked the conscience of
our nation and filled our hearts with
grief journalists like all Americans
should be free from the fear of being
violently attacked while doing their job
well we can all agree on that here's
what we know so far
the shooter killed five people wounded
two owing to a grudge apparently he had
with the paper going back a decade but
if you were watching other networks that
might not have been your takeaway I
think it's worth pointing out that we've
had a constant rhetoric coming even from
the president that the press is the
enemy of the people we have seen a spike
in threats against us since Donald
Trump's election we've joined the ranks
of Russia and third world nations where
we're reporters lives aren't safe this
rhetoric well not directly responsible
is really ratcheting up threats against
journalists it is just unfortunate that
in 2018 that's where our mind goes and
in fairness part of it goes there
because the president has declared that
the media is the enemy of the people now
this kind of over-the-top talk didn't
just come out of thin air the left for
the past week especially have been using
outrage of the border crisis to stir up
strong emotions against the
administration maybe register people to
vote as well and with that has come a
virtual call to replace all political
dialogue real debate with physical
confrontation
[Music]
we should not be terrorizing families
and children tearing migrant children
away from their parents reportedly in
some cases holding those children as
hostages as a cost to being an
accomplice to this crew deceitful
administration they got to absolutely
harassed them until they decide that
they're going to tell the president no I
can't hang with you
well when true evil strikes as it did
tragically in Annapolis Maryland
yesterday perhaps some deep breaths from
all sides are in order well Molly
Hemingway wrote a piece in The
Federalist today about this media
phenomenon she joins us along with Howie
Kurtz Fox News host of media buzz
Sundays at 11:00 a.m. and in LA attorney
Anthony tall it's great to see all of
you Molly let's start with you I mean
the rush to judgment blaming Trump
reminded me of what happened in the wake
of the Gabby Giffords shooting we saw
Sarah Palin blamed her website had the
crosshairs over I guess political
districts New York Times still raises
that even though that had nothing to do
with nutbag Jarrett Lautner who is a
psychopath neckties times still use that
debunk theory in an editorial from June
of last year after the Congressional
baseball game so this pushing of the
theories that conservatives are now in
this case Trump is responsible for this
crazy person who had a grudge it frankly
it's nothing no well and it's just so
bad to do speculation in general in the
absence of facts it was bad enough to
see many people in the media trying to
blame Donald Trump before anybody knew
what was happening was really alarming
was that they kept with it even after
the facts came out showing that there
was no correlation between Donald
Trump's very strong criticism of the
media and the shooting at the newspaper
in Annapolis and that's really really
bad for the media themselves because
they are under attack by a president who
does have strong criticism of them and
they played right into the hands by
creating a false narrative about the
shooting Howie the media obviously has
been under a lot of pressure shrinking
staffs budgetary constraints and now
this they've had a very cantankerous
relationship with the president there
we'll numbers are way down and now this
I'm gonna ask Kelly and Conway about
this in a few moments but your take away
this is reprehensible it's guilt by
association and it's being spread by
journalists who want to blame Donald
Trump for everything including rain
storms and rush hour traffic now I don't
agree that the president should be
calling the press the enemy of the
American people but Laura it is an
absurd stretch to go from that to this
blood on his hands claim which is a
blood libel Anthony your reaction to the
rush to blame this president maybe you
agree with some of the critics I agree
that the president's rhetoric does not
help the environment it's he directly
the blame no but you know it's just like
the old story where you have the mother
cat who has three legs and she hobbles
and then all of our kittens start
howling that's what the president has
fed this country's fed this country a
lot of rhetoric and people out there
picking on it and and we've become
kittens and we start following the
things that that that become not not
pretty powerful in our country so no
it's not there's not blood directly on
the president's hands but to say that
the environment isn't so toxic that it
could lead to something like this is not
true as well we had Michael Bloomberg
speculating that after the Times Square
attempted bombing that it could have
been someone with a political grudge
let's say someone who was against Obama
care I went back and watched that golden
oldie before the show so again the
speculation it always seems to go
against the conservative that's what I
think people find so frustrating I mean
I do agree that the way people talk can
create bad atmospheres we all need to
clean it up a year ago we had the
Republicans on the baseball field shot
up by an activist who was motivated by
political Bernie Sanders and thews
and we didn't we didn't have these
lengthy conversations about how uncivil
rhetoric or a media complex that gets
people all upset about everything all
the time whether that played a role if
you're going to claim that rhetoric
plays a role you need to be consistent
about it no matter who is the target or
victim Howie
a lot of folks are going back to this
there's a you know quaint old idea that
the press should be calling balls and
strikes and for a lot of us who've
witnessed just how this is
uncovered that this presidency has been
covered from day one the press doesn't
seem to be doing its job in many cases
there are some great reporters out there
but today we had Jim Acosta shouting as
the president was doing a speech on I
guess an anniversary of the tax bill
yeah shout do we have the tape on that
yeah let's watch
[Applause]
I you get the sense that they're just
doing it because they know it's gonna be
clipped it's gonna be a YouTube mom I
mean at some point you're not he's not
gonna say oh you in the back way in the
back I'll answer he's not gonna do that
well I mean too many organizations are
playing to an anti-trump audience now
unfortunately some of these shrinking
audience Howie
yes that is true unfortunately and some
of these after this some of these other
mass shootings I have seen people on the
right and the left sometimes trying to
score partisan points I don't like it on
either side it's being weaponized
against President Trump and here's
what's really sad Laura five people who
came to work everyday in Annapolis to
try to serve their community taking risk
as journalists because you write things
that make people angry they're dead and
that's being overshadowed by all of this
overheated political rhetoric and the
attempt to tie president Trump would you
like his rhetoric or not to this
bloodshed is really sad Anthony over the
weekend you saw the clip we played and
now pretty much everyone has seen it of
Maxine Waters and she used words like go
out and harass them basically telling
people driving them out of public
driving people out of public places
gas stations with their family now it
doesn't matter you know get up in their
faces push them back push back on them
that kind of rhetoric what about that
what about what we what that says to the
hundreds and thousands of protesters out
there against ice and against do you
know senators I guess whoever voted for
Trump is that healthy no that's not
healthy at all but I think Maxine Waters
point was to protest I think she was
very in artful and explaining herself
and I want to give her the benefit of
the doubt and say she was she's she's a
70 plus year-old woman she's been in
politics since 1992 you're telling me
that she didn't understand what she was
saying in front of that microphone she
knows exactly what she's saying this is
about registering people to vote this is
about keeping a perpetual state of
outrage among the people as the economy
is improving and opportunities are
expanding I think she knows exactly what
she's saying because she's been saying a
version of it Anthony for years and
years and years I would say decades
she's been saying
version of what she said Saturday well I
like I said I'm gonna give her the
benefit of the doubt but I understand
where you're coming from but I do want
to say that she never said there was not
any specific language and there's
nothing wrong with protests I don't
agree with harassing individuals at
restaurants I don't agree with getting
in someone's face blocking their way you
know their right of passage but
harassment she used that word yeah she
did she knows she knows well I go back
to olenski's rules for radicals I read
that today too just for fun just for you
know you know bathroom reading keep the
pressure on rule eight you know always
change your tactics don't become old
news if you push them negative hard
enough it'll break through into the into
the to the other side it's you see a lot
of that in the protest culture today
Molly's
it's it's it's high-pitched and it's
sustained and it's this is what you need
to do and it's it's Linda Sarsour
everyone's Linda Sarsour now and it's
one thing for political activists to do
it it's entirely another thing when you
see the media enabling it as well or
cheering on some of these mob attacks
and it really is important that we have
some shared space so we can have
discussions about important issues such
as border enforcement and whatnot
we don't have a media environment that's
creating a place for people to push back
have a real debate and a real
conversation and everybody needs to
ratchet down the rhetoric I think we can
all agree on I agree with that thanks so
much guys